hi there and welcome back to the future
of documents i'm holt skinner and i'm a
developer advocate for google cloud in
the last video we talked about document
ai and how we can extract structured
data out of unstructured documents
in this video we'll get started using
document ai with the cloud console and
api with the python client library for
the most up-to-date information be sure
to check out the documentation linked in
the description
[Music]
before we start processing documents we
need to understand document ai
processors
a document ai processor is an interface
between the document file and a machine
learning model that can be used to
classify split parse or analyze a
document
you will have to create processor
instances in your project to use
document ai this is different from how
the ml apis like vision or speech to
text work instead it's similar to how
you'd create a vm and compute engine or
a model instance in vertex ai
a processor can be general specialized
or custom
each type is designed for a specific
task such as optical character
recognition general form parsing
classification or parsing a specialized
document types
we'll dive into the specific types later
but for now let's walk through the
process to create and test a processor
in the cloud console these steps will be
similar for whatever processor type
you're using let's demonstrate with an
optical character recognition processor
you first need to navigate to artificial
intelligence and document ai
next click create processor
if you haven't already enabled the
document ai api the console will prompt
you to do this here
select the processor type you want to
create in this case document ocr
you must specify a processor name and
region when you create each processor
you can't change these later
click create
after the processor has been created you
can grab the processor id and your
project id you'll need both of these to
access the api
now you can upload a test document to
send to the processor
the console should look something like
this
you can see all of the extracted text in
sections and highlight them to identify
specific text this can allow you to
quickly check if the document is being
processed in the way you'd expect
now let's explore how to use the
document ai api allowing you to create
automated scripts to handle document
processing document ai supports a
unified api endpoint this feature offers
multiple advantages the same endpoint is
used for every type of processor you
create you specify your processor by
including your processor id and project
id in the request that you send to the
api
this means that you can use the same
client library and authentication for
every processor
additionally the responses use a
universal document structure to simplify
the development process we'll call it
the document object
it contains all the information about
the raw text layout extracted entities
languages etc
when calling the api we need to decide
how our application will process
documents
document ai supports both online and
batch processing these work similarly to
vertex ai online and batch prediction
online processing is primarily for low
latency use cases such as where the user
is waiting for results batch processing
is designed to handle larger files or
multiple documents at once the steps for
making document ai api calls are
basically the same for both online and
batch calls but the exact code will be
slightly different
first you should create a service
account for your document ai application
you need to grant the service account
the document ai api user role
after creating your service account you
can select the appropriate client
library for your application and install
it for today's examples we will use the
python client library
now let's take a look at some code for
online processing you can read more
about these examples in the codelab
linked in the description
first we need to define variables for
values needed by document ai we need the
project id location processor id a path
to a local file and the mime type of the
file
next we'll look at the key steps for
making a request
the api works the exact same way for any
processor type the only differences will
be the processor id and how you use the
data afterwards
first we need to configure the processor
client
then construct the request which
contains the processor information and
base64 encoded file
next we make a request to the api
and then we can analyze the output from
the api in our document object
now let's take a look at batch
processing it's a little more
complicated but you can process larger
documents and multiple files in a single
api call
the biggest difference is that the input
and output files are stored in google
cloud storage buckets and the api calls
are processed asynchronously this works
the exact same way for every processor
type
the code lab in the description shows
how to make these requests in more
detail
let's take a look at the document object
output which contains all of the data
the processor extracted
the information within the document
object can be classified into four main
categories
first we have document representation
this section contains information about
the raw text that is extracted by ocr
this section also describes the physical
layout of the document
next we have extracted data
this section describes the data that can
be represented by a well-defined schema
this structured data is stored as an
array inside the document entities field
next we have metadata this field allows
you to maintain a full revision history
of the changes made to the document
last we have annotations this field is
mainly used in the human in the loop or
hitl workflow hitl provides the ability
to make corrections to existing
predictions and save them in the
document object
this diagram shows some fields that are
supported by the document object these
fields capture the information that is
extracted from the input file let's look
at some examples we have a sample
document shown on the left with the
document output shown on the right in
jason format
you can see the text field contains the
raw text within the document and the
mime type field shows that this is
extracted from a pdf file
the pages field provides information
about the layout and structure of the
document
looking at the same sample document we
can see that the pages field includes
the page number dimensions and layout
information we'll return to this
document object in later videos to
explore other fields we've covered quite
a lot about document ai in this video we
learned about document ai processors and
how to create them we learned how to use
a processor to parse a document with
both online and batch processing and we
explored the document object structure
so that we can get every last drop of
information about our files for detailed
tutorials on how to make online and
batch requests with ocr processor see
the code labs and documentation linked
in the description in the next video
we'll look more into general processors
and how we can start gathering
intelligent insights from documents
thank you so much for watching and don't
forget to like and subscribe
[Music]
you